the world is changing
truth is Vanishing
War
to describe in your words the Tom Cruise
run because it is stuff of Legends so
how would you each describe it
I would just I watched him a lot because
I was like what is this what is going on
there seems to be a direct correlation
with how much he runs in the film and
the success of the overall film yeah I
would love to see this man yes he does
and what I think it is is yes he's fast
that's not the interesting thing
watching him run in real life and it
transmits on screen he runs with every
cell in his body and it's like he's
either getting away from a bear like
it's almost Primal caveman energy
um but or it's running to something that
he's gonna kind of save and it's it I
think also his running becomes the
metaphor of his approach to anything
movie related he puts absolutely
everything into it and I think it's that
that's the thing that you feel because
anyone can kind of run fast on screen
and be made to look like they're running
even faster if they need to but there's
something about the way that he studied
the form that you can see that it has so
much of energy and power in it and he
doesn't miss close-ups too even as it is
acting what you're saying about it's
every cell even like a twinkle in his
eyes something yeah everything's awake
yeah just so present I think it is isn't
that just so totally present to the
present moment right there he's with you
even when we were at dinner last night
he's just with you you know he's not
anywhere else it's like you float off
into
themself to be able to be in the moment
and stay in the moment
um your first time in the movie I I it's
my understanding that during the
audition process it was a lengthy
process and it was more about like
creating those moments and even in the
filming and that you were put through
these physical tests were you can you
describe a little bit about that process
because it sounds so unique to what
auditioning is usually like yeah um well
Christopher Macquarie would see me in a
play 10 years ago and took me out for
dinner and said I want to work with you
I want to find the character that
bottles the thing that I know that you
can do on that stage cut to 10 years
later and he brings me in to meet Tom
for this and there was about 10 pages of
dialogue that I'd learned for it that
he'd he'd written that we knew wouldn't
be in the film but it would just be a
sort of an introduction to working with
each other and it very quickly it felt
like a we were workshopping it it didn't
feel like it was I was standing there
and I did a reading and tried a
different way and thank you very much
for the time we'll be in contact it was
do one where you're more you're
withholding information now do one where
you're totally oblivious to anything
going on around you and you think you're
just having a nice time
um now let's maybe try one we just throw
out that bit of dialogue and come up
with something else and then we look at
playback and we look what what the
lighting and the composition of the
frame was revealing about equality in my
personality on on screen and what they
felt that that might translate as a
character in this franchise and then
there was of course the physical side of
things where they were testing to see
kind of how quickly I could learn fight
choreography and then uh and sort of an
evaluation of where they thought my
natural skill set lay and where I could
get to with the right training
um and again you know because because
Chris McCrory and Tom are such students
of film they're fascinated by the
process and with everyone incredibly
inclusive of every side of filmmaking
from the technical aspect as well as the
acting so I already felt from day one
this was going to be a collaborative
process so I got a follow-up to that
what is your skill set naturally as a
fighter and did you bring your
ventriloquist skills into the audition
the thing that I felt was very clear was
partly because of my theatrical
background props for me are key to use a
very important word in the movie they
are key in they're an extension of how
she expresses herself in the world how
she feels about certain things and
certain people and so when I was doing
fight choreography if you gave me a
knife I could learn it faster my brain
actually worked better if I had
something I was holding as opposed to
just physically doing a routine without
it and that's also where the sleight of
hand tricks came in as well
um and then the other thing which was a
total surprise to me was drifting
drifting was the thing that became I
became proficient in because it for some
bizarre reason I took to it quite well
um total surprise so we never did the
room
I accept this mission that never
happened in one take
you're like no
um for you the last film there was more
fighting I feel like this one was more
character driven and I kept thinking to
myself as I was watching the film who is
she channeling like was there somebody
that you were channeling something and
then I also heard that Christopher
McCrory had you read books on Power and
sort of embracing that power so as
somebody who doubts themselves how do
you how did you sort of what did you
take away from those books the book was
really interesting it was it was mostly
saying that power doesn't need to assert
itself it's actually is more um
magnetic as in you have to attract the
sensation rather than put it out you put
it out it suggests that there's a kind
of um
a need to prove and that isn't powerful
so uh everything we talked about you
know I watched people like Lauren McCall
and those actresses who were just so
they have such a potency really and
they're not doing too much they just
have this presence so it was much more
about doing less and
um you know even when I tried takes in
Fallout that were
more fueled with a kind of anger or
something it just lost the
um the command somehow so that was the
was the key to it I think have you seen
the Philadelphia Story without burning
yeah you talk about all your power right
right exactly that that is a hundred
percent one of those
um asking also everybody today if there
was a stunt
of TOMS you have to choose one from the
franchise that you had to do which one
would you choose
what was it the one that we were talking
about earlier with on The Wire I think
of the first one
um the zip wire is there on the first
very first movie where he goes down I
know the names of it in the white room
yeah that one I think it's like exactly
because if you fall you're not falling
very fast
unless the wire
yeah that's true but um that's you know
the the the least of the the evils of
his stunts I think
the halo jump I think I've skydived a
little bit
um a few times and I love it so that was
really that was I just killed to do that
wow you I mean that to me sounds like I
don't know how to hang up we were
discussing the building the heights
you know that's not for for us no
is this the first time you worked
together yeah
for you the train sequence can you
describe the zero G's how does that feel
how is it shot like a little bit of a
breakdown from your perspective as an
actress yeah I mean like everything in
the film everything is meticulously
planned and is built up too so it
becomes a sensation in my body that I'm
familiar with as opposed to you know the
first time that I have that experience
it's your body's going what is going on
and it goes into a little bit of you
know adrenaline and so after that you'll
when you do it a second time your body's
like okay I'm familiar with this and so
it's it's easier as you go on like
anything like skydiving would be too
um and yeah um it's so fun to watch that
because it's it's a different Dynamic
within the Train the train itself is
another character the Fiat 500 is
another character so to have a design of
these different carriages having
different worlds like you have the
kitchen Carriage the piano bar the
dining room carriage and they all have
their own obstacles and things that each
character has to overcome and help each
other overcome
um you know and so much of the physical
quality comes out of that yeah what is
the most like where your stomach is like
a little is it the drifting or is it the
zero G's is it no it's um there was a
vertical train rig that goes from uh
vertical to horizontal insects six
seconds and we had to do that multiple
times and hit a certain Mark and hang
from it
um that is uh that was you know
it over time because we did it so many
times that's when it becomes more and
more challenging to sustain that level
of sprinting inclining
and then there was another part where he
says on the train Carriage you know do
you trust me and I didn't act that I
just went
no and then oh I guess I should be
saying yes and then yes and we they use
that in the film and it was just before
I meant to jump across the train
Carriage as the the piano comes crashing
down on me
um and it's that feeling of if there is
any time to think about what you're
doing that can actually paralyze you wow
and so the more time I had to think the
the scarier it was but again with Tom if
he just he's so Fearless that if you
just not don't think about it and let go
into the process you know that you're
going to be held you're always going to
be safe wow that question for you I read
that you said that Tom is that person
that makes you bring out your own
mission and feel like you can do
anything in your life what is what is it
that you now feel like is your mission
because of because of that experience
um yeah I think the all the examples
um of how he goes beyond the limit of
what most people would ever attempt to
it's kind of that it's what are your
what's the edge that you think oh I
couldn't I don't know if I could go past
that or because you said self-doubt um
for me I guess it was yeah it was just
knowing when you see Tom who's such a
cinephile and care about Cinema so much
and as act as you do you know you grow
up in films it's like changed my life
and it is my life and I just love
nothing more and um I suppose it's to
kind of go beyond the uh the Realms of
what I think is possible in that and
there's been a couple of films I've done
since the first mission and I know that
the ability to kind of believe in being
able to do that you know I had to give
birth and I hadn't given birth before
and it was just terrified me like
jumping off a cliff I just it was felt
like that because I thought if I get
this wrong I'm actually getting it wrong
on behalf of
every woman that's done it you know and
that felt yeah I didn't know if I could
do it but I just sort of thought well
you know Tom can
put his life in danger every single day
I can maybe like manage to do that
that's an example of the limit and so I
kind of try and apply that now in
different areas
[Music]
I just want to start things off I'm
asking everybody today can you both
describe the Tom Cruise run from your
opinion when I was making the World's
End in a couple of long time ago now 10
years ago now I called Tom to say I'm
about to do his Running Scene I had to
Sprint down the street and I said what
have you got any tips and I he said keep
your arms pumping your head high no keep
your knees High your arms pumping and
you head forward and that was the that's
the rule I mean that's the way but also
I would say I mean when I see it it's
also about the hand position you know
you're not like this and you're not like
relaxed you
yeah did you do that in your run in the
world I did and I actually became 32
faster
Is that real
wow I am making up but it's funny
that's amazing I'm not making up about
the idea I did call him about the right
time yeah but he he's just you know
sprinting is very good for you and I
think that's part of the reason he looks
like he does at 60. yeah no very very
true I don't know how he does it in
between doing all this dance
um
you are such a wonderful addition to
this franchise oh thank you
this franchise four films five six films
um can you talk a little bit about
becoming this character because when I
was watching you and tell me if I'm
wrong I thought she's channeling an
animal I don't know which animal it was
it was so beautiful how do you know did
you hear about that no I told people
about that it's called the shoe Bill
stork or the shoe Bill I've seen that
thing with the big it's a crazy animal
that is prehistoric bird and that looks
insane and I would watch videos of the
bird I was like this is me
and the bird is like slowly moving and
just
I'm gonna look at the camera like this
thing
and then staring like and in the movie I
stare a lot actually so it works it does
was the makeup was that part you or was
that written in the script no the makeup
um was um so it made sense oh when I did
it yeah because people were supposed to
wear masks the other people were going
to a party and then people ended up not
wearing a mask so I look a little bit
insane but I like looking insane anyway
um no it was inspired by
um
you know it was my idea
um you know a character from Comedy
I mean we're in Italy so I'm supposed to
have the accent
um and you know with a teardrop there
was like a side of it there was a little
bit
um melancholic you know a thought fitted
the character and um and also there's
like a side of it that was like a little
bit I could pantomime so a bit like a
creepy and weird and eerie and I thought
that with this fight scene it would look
cool and because like everything was
everything was dark you know because
it's a night time so I thought that
would like bring some light to the face
as well and also with the sweat it would
be like a little bit like weird and it
would look like a monster and and
actually it worked I could never look
like a monster no but you just did it
I was just like oh I felt like you could
turn your head on this axis there for a
second it's good luck next movie maybe
there I know you're both in the middle
of filming so for you sir I made a
connection every film you get a hero
shot in Fallout you got a big beautiful
backlit shot where you came in on the
boat and you were the hero for that
moment you get it again at the Coliseum
talk about
Benji having his hero moments now he's
really evolved he has well you know he
was a kind of little lab technician in
the third one and he's gone from being a
sort of puppy dog to a much more mature
member of the team and yeah I he always
gets his his little moment and he's
always there he's kind of like you know
that they're really strong woman behind
the successful husband
and that's what Benji is and McHugh's
always really great at making sure
personally I think he does this for
every single character in this film
that's one thing we thought when we
watched it
was that everybody has their moment you
know and there's a beautiful moment I
love the shot of I won't I know no
spoilers but there's a wonderful shot of
palm where she sits down and her hands
sort of retract it's it's
he's so good at making sure every
character feels sort of um serviced in a
way and I think you bring it every
character brings her a lot of empathy to
the movie as well that he's really
needed and especially action movies like
that you know what's funny is I had the
question and I you know this go watching
these films why does he stay why every
time Ethan says you know we're gonna do
this you just you follow him no matter
how crazy yeah and then you get your
moment of why in this film yes
absolutely yeah where the AI informs why
and it's the most poignant movie so can
you talk about that line and delivering
that line was that a lot of takes was it
yeah there's a lot of well there's a lot
of kind of um Mission Impossible is is
always about the team you know even
though Ethan's there at the Forefront
and the team and what the team mean to
each other and what friendship means and
that that that the weight of friendship
these are all as you learn in this film
anyone that's in the IMF has made a
choice at some point in their life to do
so because they have been in a position
where they don't really have much choice
to do anything else other than you know
an alternative kind of Fate which isn't
so nice so Benji chose to be in the IMF
and him and he and Ethan and Luther are
very good friends and and he's jab Benji
is tested you know in this film to to
reveal what is the most important thing
to him and he has to say his friends and
and that just UPS the ante on it in
terms of all the stakes you know because
if if any of us lose each other it's
going to impact very hard so I want to
talk about your brutal I wrote the words
brutal in my screen and my screening for
your fight scene with Tom like it was
one of the most brutal fight scenes I
think of the entire series can you just
talk about pummeling Tom first of all we
call it pummeling
not pummeling pummeling oh my gosh oh
this is a new thing we have to coin them
when she beats you up which she does
quite regularly uh we get pummeled I
thought it was gonna be the Pom-Pom show
but apparently you you went up to me
that's even better it's the pomeling so
yes how
if you can just talk about how many days
that was the process of filming it how
incredible it was and is it kind of fun
to just unleash it was so much fun uh it
was um we took I mean I I rehearsed for
months and months uh we Shot the movie
for I mean I I was out of my home like
for almost like longer than a year and
we shot the fight scene at the end of
the the shoot so you know
and we you know it was like very
technical too because like the
um the alleyway was very narrow so we
needed to find a place to put the
cameras to light it properly uh for the
the kicks um the the hits to be shown
and uh but it was incredible you know
like Tom Works in such detail you know
with such Precision you know and and for
him and it's why the Mission Impossible
movies are so incredible to um with the
action it's not about the choreography
and about the movements it's about
um the characters and what happens
between them and what the the fight
tells and how the audience feels about
it so sometimes what is mo more
interesting in them in the fight is
actually the moments in between the hits
when the characters are tired when one
of the characters is down and looking up
and wanting to give up but still fights
and all these bits you know that really
create emotions you know so it was
incredible to watch him work and to get
to to do that scene with him and I kept
asking him to like just like hit me in
in here like you know to kick me because
I was like squeezing my abs like no no
because he's such a gentleman he
wouldn't do it but you know I've been
training for a long time I was like just
like ah let's go
he was like no no of course uh but you
know I'm not saying that you have to hit
each other when you do fight scenes but
just a little bit of contact if it's
controlled it helps with the scene I
think but yeah you know anyways we had a
blast it's my understanding that
Christopher actually changed shots
around because of what you were doing
that he actually went oh no this is
really interesting and actually really
changed what he was planning because you
were doing so many incredible
interesting things oh thank you yeah um
I'll just sort of end this on if there
is a stunt of Toms that you had to do
what would be the stunt from all of the
franchise we had like Gunter had had to
do you have to do don't pick an easy one
from like one two or three no well I
mean I'll tell you what one of the stuns
it gets uh that doesn't always get
um the love because it was a smaller one
but the fish tank's done from one is
incredible because that was real all
that water was coming down when he's
running beautiful
but I think for sheer fun I would like
to do the Burj Khalifa climb you know
when he's on the building yes because I
mean I remember he had such fun doing
that you know he was just smiling his
head off and I and other stuff like when
he did the plane and when he did the
bike stunt he was very focused very
concentrated because but on that Burj
Khalifa stunt he was just like a kid in
a candy shop just crawling around like
Spider-Man when no one talks about is
the landing of the plane start they talk
about the taking off but the landing
yeah it doesn't land I I watch that it
doesn't what about for you I mean I
would love to to skydive because he
introduced me to skydiving and I love it
and we even like jumped together so that
would be so much fun and also I'm
obsessed with horses as you know
I'm obsessed with horses so I would love
to do like one of the Galloping in the
desert like super fast with a horse it
would be awesome there's always eight
Palm a horse in Norway called lucky and
I think we should just give him a shout
out yeah we love you lucky we love you
lucky lucky I miss you thank you bro
he's a fjord horse he's so cute he's
like a bunny but he's like super strong
usually they're like pretty lazy the
pure horses this one goes so fast so
would you say I would just go for a ride
sir I could talk
[Music]
[Laughter]
go super fast and you never stop and he
was like so hardcore that I would have
like blisters
you need to tell Christopher to write
lucky into the next film
I met a horse he's amazing but I think
he looks too cute for a Villain Like Me
it's been a long time Family
you have no idea the power I represents
how did you get the call for this
I have no idea what do you mean I it was
a cold call it wasn't even an audition
it was how soon can you get on a plane
to London and I said why there's
interest in you for Mission Impossible
I'm like the movie with Tom
yeah and it was like you know thank you
and um we had a good conversation with
Christopher Macquarie and somehow uh the
Stars aligned for me what did he tell
you about
we tell you he hits he had seen me in
another project and he felt that I I was
possibly the right person for this role
because of the gravitas the danger The
lethality I mean no one can speak as
well as Chris Macquarie I I can't even
like he has a way with words unlike
anyone else that I've met and whether
it's on the spot or written down on
paper like thought he is he's a poet and
a real Craftsman so I just talking to
him for two hours on a zoom call was
fascinating we went over so many things
and he's about to I'll I said I'm a team
player I said whatever you need he goes
well this is not you know your contempt
your average conventional filmmaking we
move we do things it's it's not the
average you know way you make movies
can you hang with that and I was like
yes sir how would you ever say no so how
different was it an experience because
they almost work backwards in the sense
that they find what works with an actor
with a shot and then they build the
story around it that's right well the
thing is that they know movies so well
that they can actually they know a
sequence that you might think you've
seen it before like oh we've seen a
train fight before but then they look
for ways to make it something you
haven't seen before Thrills angles you
know I mean from you know everyone from
John frankenheimer to David lean is like
nodded to in these movies so if you
really know film you'll understand it
and if you don't know film you'll just
be in awe of of like the immersive
nature of this film which is why it's
important to see it on a big screen it's
important to just go there and let
yourself be transported what because we
all hear the word villain right so you
as an actor do you feel a pressure or
how do you find your way in because
there's like we always talk about the
quote-unquote villain in the film right
so it has to match the hero or else yeah
absolutely I think your Heroes the more
formidable a foe your your hero has the
bigger the mountain and um you can't
have a hill you need something ferocious
and for me it's about tapping into the
pain in my life tapping into the times
where I've had to draw deep and it's
serious stuff and I think that Macquarie
and Tom know how to capture that and
edit it and put it all together in a way
that leaves a lasting impact the movie
is haunting the character I play is
haunting I play it tied to his past at
Tom's of Ethan Hunt's past and as I've
said a couple of times I think nobody
can threaten your future more than
somebody who knows your past
did you spend any time with
Thomas
something you do well the thing is that
you know I talked to the director more
and then Tom comes in and he fine-tunes
he's he has an eye come on the guy's
been doing this at such a high level for
so long he knows what works with the
audience he knows and it's funny too I
loved watching the fun aspects so for me
this is a dream come true what is the
stun of Tom's that you wish you could do
that you would like to try
where can I start that motorcycle jump
is something that must be extremely
exuberating I mean think about it you're
on a motorcycle you're flying through
the air and then you let go the only
thing that was keeping you on the ground
and then you fly I mean I can't think of
anything closer to being a bird
and then you land hopefully that's the
key there's so much danger there's so
many pitfalls so many things could go
wrong
and he does it and he does it so well
that I just wish I had wings like he
does in this movie they're wrapping me
thank you so much no thank you and I
made sure you watch it July 12th let's
break some records let's break some
records that's that's my dream listen to
me the world's coming after you
this is a very dynamic duo did you did
Tom give you guys like an idea like this
is sort of the idea of what we want for
these guys that the chemistry between
the two of you to be
I think that grew organically honestly I
don't think it was a set plan of like
hey this is what we're doing and this is
how y'all have the behave I think uh
outside of filming we grew this Bond and
me just learning from Shea which he's a
fantastic actor obviously he has this
long career but I just you know fed off
of him on camera and I was like okay
this is how it goes and he was very
courteous not not to like say hey this
is how you should do it but just like
you know giving me his his point of view
on things and I'm like oh that's
interesting and he would also take my
life oh I love what you did there and
then it would give him something to play
off of as well so it was it was a you
know match made our character is very
conflicted and there's a moment in the
film without spoilers that you could go
one way and you go another way and I was
very surprised yeah I mean you look this
thing is fun it's big it's entertainment
but it but also these guys McHugh and
Tom I always say them together they're
looking for story they're looking for
characters that you care about you know
what I mean so even when he and I were
building this relationship the things
that I wouldn't I wouldn't tell him you
know what I mean and just so that so
that and then you you know you want
things to just evolve like you said
organically and they did did you call
your Top Gun castmates and say hi I'm
the one back I'm the one back no no no
no honestly so when I when I got the job
I was told I couldn't say anything and
I'm I'm a stickler when it comes to I
don't no one knows what's going on in
the film not I might keep my mouth shut
and uh I didn't tell them that I was in
the film at all they found pictures
because you know fans would take
pictures and it was like Tarzan is this
you they come in a group message and I'm
like no you already know it's you so I
didn't tell him anything if you didn't
even tell your castmates no no so when
you got to tell them what was their what
was the announcement like yeah uh well
they were peed off that I didn't shared
with them and they had to find out on
their own and it was just like surprise
guys I'm here I love it so I've been
asking everybody today which of Tom
stunts you most want to do from the
franchise but I think in your case I'm
going to ask you both to invent his
stunt
that you would both like to do in the
next mission Impossible film as a Duo if
you can oh man if we were in the next
one and you got to do a brilliant stuff
that if we got to do the next mission
Impossible film
um
dang that's a good one what would be the
stunt uh I don't know I think I'd use
that backdrop right behind us right
there so you would come back to home is
what you're saying try to jump between I
do like a nice foot chase
over the beautiful buildings right there
maybe you know something I would like
that I wonder if they can invent jet
packs or something I would I would say
let's let's do some jet packing all
right so which one are you doing from
the previous yeah that's a that's a good
one I know what are you gonna do oh from
any of the Physicians I would do the uh
when he climbs on the Burj Khalifa
because he was like Spider-Man and I
really want to like do that that was so
cool never been done before fly out the
window face first fly out the window for
oh
oh and you know what you know what what
if you know you break the window and you
fly out and have the 30 to uh parachute
and you have to put it on before hitting
the ground and then letting it go that
would be the stunt I would want to do so
you're combining two stunts yes being
innovative
I I love when he's hanging off the side
of the plane
and then it takes off I that's one that
I I still can't get over when I see you
know I love that one
you know I think that's something that I
could maybe do you know what I mean that
would be that'd be cool last question
what is one thing that you can do now
because of this training like how
intense was this training and what is
something that you're super capable of
now that you couldn't do before and how
did it compare to the topic
oh uh what I can do now is uh
um
I can ride motorcycles I wasn't
necessarily the best at it I'm really
good at it now
um and compared to Top Country Top Gun
was its own thing where we had to learn
how to fly planes and get into F-18 and
I say that so casually like oh I've
learned everything
um that was one thing but with this one
we had to learn an array of skills uh so
it was more daunting because you have
non-stop like this this this this this
so uh which one is harder I don't know I
can't put a channel a difficulty level
on it but it was intense I missed
driving
be able to drive you know uh with Wade
Eastwood and I I love it I can't I can't
get enough of that
he didn't know how to drive at first uh
drifting and all that I to me it was one
of the great things about this was to be
able to them and trust me to do all the
driving we did a ton of it I mean a ton
of it through these streets and with
cameras mounted four cameras mounted I
could barely see and you know it was to
me it was it was I was like a kid in a
candy store someone just broke into a
car yeah somebody's about to go dripping
this fader's written shall we write
yours too if anything
there's no place that I won't go to kill
you that is right now
after every Mission Impossible movie the
very first screening yes Tom leans over
and Whispers in your ear and says we can
do better I was hoping you were going to
do it your best Tom Cruise voice that
was as good as I could do that's as good
as I can do it that is amazing to me and
if it was any other actor saying that I
would be like well that's insulting but
with Tom he actually does it and you
actually do it and I didn't think you
could top fall out and you did wow thank
you so how the heck do you top yourself
what what practically when he says that
what does that mean for you as a
director that means we take everything
we learn from what we've just done and
we apply it to the next thing and really
everything we've learned
in everything we've done together and
everything we've done separately uh
We're Never Satisfied we're looking at
those sequences and and there's there's
what you dream of the sequence being and
then there's what you ultimately end up
with yeah we don't settle for that we're
looking at it and saying now okay we
could have done better how do we how do
we apply it so you're what you're seeing
in uh in dead reckoning part one is uh
if everything we learned from previous
motorcycle stunts everything we learned
from previous skydiving gags now we put
the motorcycle in the skydiving together
I see what you did there uh yeah and uh
and and sequences we've always dreamed
of doing we're talking about things long
in advance we've been talking about some
sort of base jump for a long time we
were talking about some sort of sort of
a train sequence some sort of a
submarine sequence for a long long time
and you just they eventually just
percolate to the surface so for you as
you know when you're setting up your
shots how does that actually look
because the the helicopter sequences in
Fallout were incredible so visceral but
I feel like this is the first film where
I felt like I was inside the film
instead of watching it yeah so for you
like when you're doing the zero g scene
how are you improving on yourself in
terms of your where you're putting your
shots in that more and more it is about
uh the the emotion that I'm that I'm
after is in the frame it's not about
watching people have an emotional
experience it's framing it in an
emotional way putting the camera in such
a place where I feel it before we put
the actors in before we and before we
call Action that was really something
that evolved for me during Fallout where
I realized even a shot of
of a of a key
you have to feel it it's got to be done
in such a way that it gives you an
emotional reaction instead of just being
information so you've teased that both
of these films are mods
how are they going to differentiate
themselves I read something about this
one's sort of simmering and then the
next one is just going to be Bonkers
yeah you're it's it's a Continuum the
story is growing from a from from the
beginning of act one of part one you
feel an escalation throughout the movie
that escalation continues in in part two
it's not a reset it it takes off right
from there will the tone feel the same
or will it feel a little bit it's hard
to say I would tell you I would I would
not be cheeky I would tell you if I knew
I they're such organic things that uh we
tend to go where
where the emotions take us I know from
the things I've already shot that
they're they are similar enough but
they've the same way that we apply
everything we've learned we've been
doing that in real time to the second
movie yeah I know you've only shot a
part of it I want to go to
your camera time in the featurette of
the jump yes some Beautiful Moments
there sir and I know they were very real
can you describe jump one
because you kind of held your breath for
that one and then after that you were a
little bit more celebratory but that
feeling as I'm sure his stomach is going
how is it for you
um you well we practiced the stunt many
many times you've seen the featurette we
were in a quarry he had a cable between
two cranes and it was all that was all a
camera test that was really just to find
a place to put the camera and it was for
Tom to develop the sense of the of the
bike the wind speed because he couldn't
be looking at a speedometer we were
eliminating all the variables
um what you couldn't predict was the
difference between jumping off of a say
a hundred foot high ramp in into that
quarry and a 2000 foot drop and you you
couldn't you couldn't lens out the shot
you just didn't know what it was going
to look like and uh and there were
certain factors that we simply couldn't
predict which meant that no matter how
much you rehearsed it when you went
there on day one you really didn't know
what was going to happen we we also had
very calm conditions and very controlled
conditions and in Norway there was
crosswind yeah there were there were all
these variables and we were determined
not to do the shot with a helicopter
because we didn't want to blow Tom off
the rant when we got to Norway we
discovered the only way for us to get
the shot was to do it with a helicopter
and so that shot was improvised for all
of the time that we had spent we decided
the camera the the helicopter guys came
up to us and said we actually think we
can get the shot
and and we ended up doing it with a
helicopter so when Tom took off my first
thought was the helicopter could just
blow him off the ramp and if he goes off
the ramp the parachute's not going to
save him
um once he went off the ramp I thought
the helicopter could easily follow the
bike Tom could get tangled up there were
a million different things that we had
eliminated which it all now come back so
imagine spending months eliminating all
the things that could be dangerous and
then on the day you go to shoot you
reintroduce all of them doing them all
at once so it truly as much as we knew
we knew nothing from when he went off
the ramp and there are very few
instances where we don't
no
pretty pretty sure how it's going to
turn out so that was really that was
quite terrifying the other factor is he
had six seconds and he had to count
those seconds he had six seconds before
he had to deploy the parachute and if he
didn't he was not going to have enough
room and so those six seconds which
in in real time don't feel like a lot
just stretched on first so eternity mi8
you said the only thing that made you
more nervous than that is what you're
going to do in the next one you tend to
shoot I think everything in the
beginning all the really tough stuff
yeah is the toughest stuff in the can no
no really the
something so hairy is in the can the
hardest thing is Yet to Come is that the
aerial sequence the aerial sequence we
did in Africa was definitely that was
definitely to date the most terrifying
thing we've done actually yeah that was
extreme like what you can see some
pictures on the internet that'll that'll
give you a pretty good indication of
what it is I think watching this one I
think I have an idea
I think the audience is going to have an
idea yeah of what you're doing
that you maybe haven't shot yet am I
correct in my assumption um
uh the very end shot should give you an
indication of what's coming in part two
we knew he was gonna do this yeah either
jumping between planes or going doing a
submarine type situation you won't be
disappointed either way um the AI I
don't know if you're prophetic because
this was obviously
written a few years ago such a hot topic
now
um could this have because it feels to
me there's been a lot of villains this
feels like the the villain I can
understand the most and the one that
feels like most it could happen it's
I'll tell you it's uh it's an idea we
talked about for a long time
um and when I first presented the idea
to Tom uh this was in about 2019 I said
this is an idea that would have been
a little too abstract
for audiences even a few years ago but I
feel people becoming more and more aware
of how much their lives are affected by
technology so we were and we saw it
growing at such a rate what we didn't
anticipate was the the time it would
take to make the movie and the
acceleration of technology for it to to
meet the way that it has I think um
everybody
about the stunts the thing that I love
about Tom is what an Exquisite actor he
is and the one thing that I love that
you do is you you hold on shots where
he'll tell the team I got you and you'll
hold on it just long enough
can you see the doubt yes can you talk
as a director working with him
some of those moments where you were
just awed by him as an actor yeah I have
to say he's Tom is he is completely
emotionally connected to the narrative
and what you're seeing is you're we're
navigating this story through a sense of
of the emotional connection to the
characters whether it's through action
whether it's through drama and he has
this innate sense of when he is feeling
the audience connecting with the
characters and losing that connection it
isn't about Tom the star it's about
Ethan
the character it's about Maverick the
character it's it's the protagonist and
a protagonist-driven narrative and uh
and so his relationship with the team
and and the way different characters
introduce themselves the way they
comport themselves in the story that's
all done by sense of feel we're working
our way through a scene we think it's a
great idea of the day and we get there
and we're stepping back from it and
looking at it going I'm not feeling it
I'm not really connected to this person
the information the plot the story none
of that stuff matters as much or rather
it can all give way instantly in favor
of I'd have to be connected to the
characters and one of the things I'm
most proud about this movie weather at
character is it hero villain antagonist
you're connected to those characters you
feel an affinity for them and that's
really a testament to the cast they're
this is truly an extraordinary top to
bottom amazing cast what are you going
to do after eight when he whispers in
your ear
we can do better uh we have ideas really
you're gonna go beyond we have ideas
yeah we're always talking it's it's one
long conversation about movies
interrupted by production every so often
my very last question Palms character
you've talked for about how you base
some of these films off silent films in
a sense yes was her character based off
a silent film character no her character
was uh what really inspired her
character was
um when Palm first came in to read we
did a we did a camera test it wasn't an
audition we were just we don't write a
role and then go look for an actor we
cast actors and then find the role and
we were doing camera tests with palm and
learned only in that test that her that
her first language was French
and as soon as we heard that I had
written a scene for her I said stop
speaking let's just speak French for the
rest of the day she said the audience
won't understand you I said it's an
international spy movie it doesn't
matter and she started doing French with
Tom and it changed her body language it
changed her entire comportment
and then we started taking lines away
and he realized she was so expressive
without having to say anything
and the the the the funniest part of
production is Palm would come to work
every day saying where are all my lines
I don't have any dialogue and I just
listen all the dialogue everybody else
is explaining the plot of the movie you
don't have to
and you've got the best job on this
movie
um and she's such a force of nature
she's such a powerful presence she just
didn't need it she was she she was
that's what we were feeling every time
we looked at her in the frame and then
when she finally does speak
you listen yeah I heard you say she's
the best actor you've ever worked with
I'm like you know you've worked with Tom
Cruise I would oh no yeah I would say
the best actor I've ever worked was
she's she what I was saying in that
interview is just she she that her power
how compelling she is she all Palm has
to do is stand there and you just you
can't take your own keyboards yeah